pembrokeshire known for its lush
countrysides stunning coastlines and
well rain but between march and july
this year it only saw 60 percent of
expected rainfall
great for the thousands of tourists that
visit here but not for its reservoirs as
the country may be heading to drought i
use this reservoir that we stood in
front of full but an hour and a half up
the road they're experiencing problems
okay so that really relates to the size
of the catchment and the shape of the
geography which catches the rainfall
generally wales is always wet would be a
perception but it's not truly the case
and prolonged periods of dry weather
that we're experiencing can cause
stresses on the water environment should
be a prolonged dry spell um are
animals associated with the riverine
environment so salmon um fishes
in some of the the rivers um the the act
as a food source for other animals so it
might be things like otters and so forth
that have returned to those rivers could
be challenged but
at the moment that's not the case but
unless it rains very hard and very soon
pembrokeshire and camardensia will have
to face a hosepipe van from the 19th of
august to ensure that there's enough
water for the rest of summer but bruce
who runs a 320 acre farm is already
running low this would normally be going
over the weir this would be full so it'd
be about seven foot deep
um and literally going over that weir at
the end and this would be full
you know but a potato will wither if
it's not watered so there will be a lot
of irrigation happening around
pembrokeshire at the moment huge amounts
of water coming out of rivers and
irrigation ponds so it's the cost of
getting that water out of those ponds
those ponds are ending up like this
cracked and dry i'm hoping most farmers
will manage to get a crop
where there's no irrigation they won't
be getting crops it is too dry for
potatoes in this weather
bruce also supplies water for the
community garden next door and planters
here are already starting to adapt
i usually have a shower but actually
i've taken to having a bath which sounds
counter productive
but i find that if i
keep the water in let it go cold and the
next day i use it as irrigation for the
garden it goes a long way
the hosepipe ban will only apply to
around two percent of the population in
wales so most houses won't be affected
but still welsh water asking for their
customers not to waste water ironic
considering between 2020 and 2021 they
wasted around
170 million liters every day
i gotta be honest it does feel like a
joke because 2022 and i can't believe
that we go back into host bike pads i
could understand it in the 70s
dai remembers the extreme heats of 76
but this time it's different
now he runs a small gardening company
and is worried about its future
our business has gone down dramatically
due to the
the dryness if it carried on like this
next year we would have to half the
workforce we're in because
we're not having anywhere near enough
work to keep the boys busy
welsh water says that tackling leakages
is a key priority and that they're
already making headway but if we are to
expect more hot weather and less rain
suppliers have to ensure they do all
they can to save every drop shimon
freeman powell sky news